we now move on our third talk
for today and it is my pleasure to
introduce you
dr melanie spears from principal
research scientist at the ontario
institute
for cancer research the title of our
talk
is assessing new biomarkers of response
to anchor cycling's breast cancer
dr spears the stage is yours
so today i'm going to talk to you on the
assessing immune biomarkers in response
to anticycline
treatment and breast cancer as most of
you are aware
um one in eight women will develop
breast cancer
in their lifetime in canada there was
approximately 27
200 new cases diagnosed last year and
this accounts for 25
of new cancer diagnoses in females
there was approximately 5 000 breast
cancer related deaths in 2019
breast cancer is made up of four
subtypes the luminal a
luminal b triple negative and her2
positive and treatments include surgery
radiation chemotherapy
anti-hormone therapy and targeted
therapy today i'm going to focus on the
chemotherapy side of things
chemotherapy in the form of
polychemotherapy is used to
treat high-risk breast cancer patients
anthracyclines
are a form of chemotherapy and has been
shown to improve patient outcome
compared to traditional cmf therapy
however with the advent of
anthrocyclines there's also
side effects and so there's considerably
toxic side effects
and so it's important that we identify
those patients who are going to respond
to antipsychotherapy
versus those who won't there is evidence
that suggests that chemotherapy such as
anthrocyclines are immunomodulating
and so immune in primary immune response
tumor infiltrating lymphocytes have been
shown to be associated with a better
better prognosis
and triple negative and her2 positive
subtypes
in particular in the new advent setting
tills are have been shown to predict for
a pathological complete response in
response to anthrocycline and taxing
therapy
whereas in the adjuvant setting there
are confliction reports
and so the protective value of
pre-existing anti-tumor huma
immune response isn't clear
paper by shooting loy and colleagues
were showed that
in triple negative phenotype patients
who had high
tills did significantly better in terms
of disease-free survival
compared to those that had the er
positive her2 luminal subtype
and even those in the her2 positive
subtypes
when people have looked at the tumor
micro environment they have used
typical hd slides and so they have like
pathologists have looked at the tills in
that
respect and so there is a till working
group
that is deriving the best methods and
best practices for
calculating till scores and scoring
these slides
however what the slides don't give us is
the actual cell abundance and the makeup
of the immunomic environment so it
doesn't give us
what the breakdown of each cell is there
and so with this in mind
our study uh looked at the predictive
value of the immune biomarkers
to anticyclins in a breast cancer
clinical trial called br9601
furthermore we wish to examine the
immune landscape in early breast cancer
patients
treated prior to treat prior to their
treatment of anthrocycline therapy
the br9601 clinical cohort was a phase
three adjuvant clinical trial that was
randomized
into patients received receiving either
four rounds of epirivasin
followed by four rounds of cmf or they
were randomized to the second arm which
is eight rounds of cmf
the trial originally recruited 384
patients
and we have clinical follow-up of
approximately 12 years for these
patients
it is important to note that these
patients
were all treated pre-hercepting era
so the experiment at outline was as such
the br9601 clinical cohort was made into
tissue microarrays and we had
321 patients available these were across
three slides we used nanostring's
technology app for
access platform and used our immunon
oncology
panel the panel was derived of
a module containing the immune cell
profiling a module containing
the immune activation immune cell typing
tumor profiling and the immune oncology
drug targeting that module
and then we selected rois based on
tissue microenvironment versus the tumor
so the the regions of interest that we
were selected were based on the entire
tma core so one tumor core uh
contained two regions of interest so the
the trimmer mask was stained with the
pancetta keratin antibody and you can
see this on the left hand side
uh the mask below shows the white which
was the areas which were selected
the tumor microenvironment was selected
based on the cd45 a pan leukocyte
antibody
and again you can see below this the
white area denotes the marked area that
was
selected for white area
this slide just gives you an overview of
the type of
cores that we were seeing so the tissue
microwave was
generated and back in the day
when we first started the clinical trial
and so you can see they're selected for
a tumor only um however you can see that
there's
areas that have high um infiltrates that
you can see the bottom
right hand side here and we have areas
which have a lower
lower immune infiltrator but they're
still present in sort of top left here
so the actual dsp analysis so as i said
originally the br9601 recruited 374
patients
we made tissue microarrays from 321
patients
but the actual dsp expression analysis
was performed on 256 patients
these were equally distributed in that
129 of those patients received epirusion
and 120 received cmf only
the first sort of analysis we did was we
compared
our dsp analysis with a traditional in
historic chemistry ihc so on the
left-hand side you can see a plot that
gives us
um k-67 staining with ihd and that's
along the bottom
x-axis and then you can see the dsp uh
tumor t67 staining
on the the y-axis and here we see a
correlation of 0.66
on the right-hand side we have a
correlation looking at her2 expression
so again on the x-axis we can see ihd
her2 scores versus the tumor her2 scores
from the dsp and here we have a
correlation
of 0.81 so within this analysis we can
see that there are significant
correlation between the dsp
and ihd analyses
we also looked at predictive clustering
by regions of interest morphology
and then you can see here that the tumor
expression
cluster together compared to the tme
cluster in a different
way alt denoting that the expression
between the tumor and the tremor mic
environment can be very different
we then went on to look at the
differential protein expression based on
distant relapse free survival
so this volcano plot gives you single
protein expressions
in orange we have protein expression the
tumor compartment and in blue we have
a protein expression based on the tumor
micro environment
and we looked at a false discovery rate
of 10
so within this analysis we had 14
proteins that were statistically
significant associated with
distant relapse tree survival and these
included ffe
alpha e7h3 and cd8
within the tumor microenvironment
compartment we had 13 proteins that were
significantly associated with distant
relapse free survival
and these included fibronectin f b alpha
again
and b spell
we then went on to look at the
correlation between the probes
and we were able to show that there's a
large cluster of co-expressed immune
proteins there's a strong correlation
between
tumor t cell markers uh with macrophages
in the t
in the tumor microenvironment there was
also negative correlation of strong
markers
such as fibronectin and epcam in the
tumor microenvironment
with some of the immune proteins such as
b73 e7 h3
and ctla4
we derived a t-cell score using the
average expression of cd3
and cd4 and cd8 and we weren't able to
say that there was
a wealth of patients that had
t cell invasion you can see this denoted
in the red
we had patients where we see t styles
exploded so there were there was t-cells
present but they were did not invade
into the
into the tumor and then we have an area
where there's t-cell cold
as it is expected to see in breast
cancer
we also went on to show that proteins
that were most associated with t
cell explosion so in this blue
compartment were fibrin actin and b7h3
and here's the figures that show this so
high tumor t
scale scores were really occurred in the
presence of high
uh b7 or h3 or fibrinectin in the titan
tumor microenvironment
indicating this would be an interesting
analysis to do some further analyses
with
furthermore we then went on to look at
some of the other pathway important
pathways and cell types expressions in
the treatment micro environment
as this volcano plot gives just hazard
ratios again with the distance from
electricity survival
and the blue denotes the tumor
microenvironment proteins or pathways
and then and they sort of marine color
we give the the
proteins or the pathways that are in the
tumor compartment
within the tumor microenvironment we saw
the high expression of myeloid
suppression
mhc2 apoptosis and macrophages were
associated with improved dystrophy
survival
however when we look at the tumor
compartment we can see that
fibroblasts and checkpoint inhibitors
are associated with a poorer
survival um when we look at the tumor
compartment
if we look at some of the single
biomarkers as a productive
predictive or prognostic biomarkers so
these um
these grass should count the mars of
survival with their distant relaxed free
survival
so the top graph gives us the prognostic
uh role of the outcome
in the tumor micro environment um across
the bottom we have
the time in years and then we have the
percentage of a distant relapse free
survival
uh blue denotes the patients that have
low expression and then residents
patients with high expression
and we can see that epcom with patients
with a high high epcam
in the tumor microenvironment do worse
compared to the most withdrawal
expression
if you look at the bottom two
capillaries this looks at the predictive
value of anthracyclines
so on the left-hand side side we can see
patients that have lower
marker expression on the right hand side
with higher marker expression
the blue line denotes those patients
they were treated with cmf
versus the red line which patients
treated with ecmf
and we can see that statistically
patients that had a high epican
and were treated with edwards and did
significantly better than those that
were treated with the stmf
only indicating that this could be a
potential uh predictive biomarker of
anticycline response
some of the other ones that we looked at
are fxb alpha in the tumor compartment
as a potential biomarker
again the top half the top capital
mirror gives us the prognostic
um significance of this marker and we
can see that again
patients had low expression of fbi alpha
i did better
compared to those of the higher
expression and again we see that there
is
uh there is changes in those patients
that have low back expression when
treated with epilepsy
compared to cmf and the law marker and
the high marker
but none of these are significantly
significant
and finally we looked at hldr in the
tumor microenvironment as potential
biomarker
again we can see that higher expression
of
hldr improves the patient's outcome
in response to prognostics with respect
of treatment
whereas if we look at the differences in
the patients between
treated with epidural cmf there was no
significantly
a difference in these echo or
so in summary dsp was successfully used
to analyze a small clinical core of
breast cancer patients
we saw differences in expression and
tumors tumor compartment versus a
tumor microenvironment there's
significantly differential expression of
proteins
identified with 13 proteins in the
tissue microenvironment
and 14 proteins in the tumor compartment
analysis of the pathways and cell types
identified numerous pathways and self
ties that were
prognostic in this setting and we have
potential predictive biomarkers
including webcam and hltr
and these are the people that actually
helped us perform the study
thank you dr spears for a very nice talk
i have some question for you too can you
please
comment why it is important to look at
the role of the tumor microenvironment
in the antracycline response
it's important to look at anthrocyclines
in the tumor microenvironment and that
we know that some patients respond to
anthracycline and some patients don't
as i said during my presentation the use
of anthracycline can be
significantly toxic to these patients
and so we really need to identify
a biomarker response so identifying
those patients who
will respond and those patients that
don't uh we've looked at the tumor
microbiota the tumor
now for a number of years and so i think
it's important to now look across the
tumor microenvironment
as we learn more and more about the
the area
thank you what novel information
did the geomics technology show that
other technology
couldn't achieve
i think the dsp allowed us to look at
across numerous
proteins uh within one single slide
and so we're able to identify new and
potential uh predictive biomarkers of
response
thank you very much how could this work
be used in the pre-clinical setting
some of the work that we could be doing
the pre-clinical setting includes
looking at somebody's organized and how
the microenvironment plays a role in
treatment response
and i think this is where we could use
potentially the dsp technology
thank you how could the results present
here
have an impact in the clinical setting
i think the results here need to be
validated but i think with the dsp has
the potential to identify new biomarkers
that could be both proteomic and rna and
they could be
essentially then moved into the clinical
aspect
the next steps for this study would be
to validate any new findings and publish
it
we also have another other studies that
we want to look at and look at the micro
environment and the role it plays
in in breast cancer pathology
thank you again dr spears for your
presentation and discussion